Hey, good afternoon, Tim.
Hey, good afternoon. How are you doing, man?
Doing good, how about you?
Doing, doing okay. Yeah, no, just running a little late, so sorry, I'm just going to be on my phone today. But no, we just been pretty busy and kind of, we had a, I'm sure the guys have told you, and I think I've talked to you, but we had the reduction in force, so we lost a
Yeah, Vaid.
team member and kind of working through that of, you know, who's picking up what and just really enjoy working with the guys. You know, Abel's been incredible to, you know, he's always asking me, you know, hey, is there anything else I can do, anything more? And I just love that because I think that's really the big success story for us is, you know, yes, we're kind of in struggling times right now as a company.
Yeah.
kind of holistically, not as a region, but as a bigger company, trying to figure out how do they manage cost? How do they manage, you know, all the efficiency parts of what we do? And, you know, I think, you know, for us, it's looking at what each of us are working on, making sure that we're working on the right things.
you know, and really when it comes to our overall trajectory, you know, just I think for us to, you know, one ticket at a time, you know, making sure that, you know, that we're, because I think the part that we struggle with now, as we know, we have pretty much accountants running our business now. And so it's really hard when
you know, we used to thrive on the relationship component. And I think those are things that, you know, we really, you know, each of us have control of our customer service and what we give to each customer. But, you know, at the end of the day, it's, you know, just driving as much as we can. But
Also, you know, we can't do more than, you know, what's possible. You know what I mean? Like, it's so anyway, it's just really setting expectations of just do good work as best you can and, you know, I'll help facilitate and organize. And I think that's the speech I gave this morning in our sales meeting is because
Yeah.
On the sales team, they're restructuring, trying to, really trying to fit our team into kind of the bigger data prize team. On the sales side, because we've always been hybrid, meaning we're supposed to be going and selling or finding new customers, but also maintaining our customers. Well, in data prize, that's two different roles.
And we've been struggling because, you know, they've set unrealistic expectations on both sides, but for one person. And I'm like, that's not going to work, you know. So we've done a really good job, I think, of explaining, kind of pushing back and, you know, putting some efficiencies around that to help drive the sales so that we can
Because we're just not spending enough time with our current customers. And so they're feeling it. They're feeling like we're rushing them. They feel like we're doing drive-by service. We're not doing the, you know, deeper discussions that, you know, in more, just that deeper level of conversation.
And so those are things that I'm working on with our sales guy and team and just saying, you know, let's really focus on the relationship while we can and see where that takes us. But I see that Natalie's on here. Sorry, I'm just on my phone. So I'm just sitting in my truck in the target parking lot is where I'm at right at the moment.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Yeah.
Yes, nice.
But I think in what Natalie and I were talking about is at some point, I'm going to pitch, I need more IT by design resources just because it's kind of, I think we have a perfect model. And I think those are things that, you know, if...
The more, okay, I get that, yes, we need more on-site people that can do the handshakes and the, but if I can figure out a way to help with, right now our escalations are being stuck and bottlenecked in tier 2 and tier 3, thank God we have Abel in that we magically came up with that plan and we didn't lose him because
Yeah.
Right now, our success that we have is all, and I'm going to say it, all based on Abel's, not only his ability to jump in and help, but not afraid to jump in and help. There's so many people that are afraid to call a customer or afraid to, you know, jump in and like, hey, let's figure this, you know, and even this week we had an outage with
Yeah, yeah.
our most difficult customer. And I just want to give you guys this feedback because this is like...
This customer is on the scale of he's up there as being the most difficult I've ever worked with. He's, you know, condescending, narcissistic, you know, and that kind of feeds into that smartest man in the room. You can't tell him anything. Well, there was an outage with their system that
Somehow, some way, we've we set up on the on our Pro Service side, and then they handed it off to us to support. Well, I miss, somehow, some way, our entire operations team missed the whole support handoff meeting, horrible. They had an outage, and I'm like, "Wait, we don't, and that just triggered him and...
put them into this, you guys suck, you know, so we have, we're in a hole that we're trying to dig out of.
I spend a lot of time, oops, just one second, in recovery trying to help, you know, figure out how to help them with what we're doing and where we're at there. But he, anyway, Abel was doing fantastic work. He sent a update and a ticket. I get an escalation during the escalation, like.
what is Abel taught his, you know, the obfuscation, the, you know, non-clarity, the, you know, he's not helping. And I'm like, yes, like, so it's the, there's still going to be those customers that don't.
They're impossible to please, you know, and and so I don't think any.
I think I remember hearing about this guy before where you had to intervene and he was taking up a lot of your emotional bandwidth.
Yes, yes.
Oh, and it's like he's, oh, it's so hard, so hard. And it's like every time we get rid of 1, we get another one. And it's like, okay, so I've realized that we'll always have one of these guys that is like impossible to work with, but we need them because they're our biggest customer. We can't get rid of them.
You know, and anyway, it's just, there's a lot there that you're like, oh man, but I just don't want it to come back on evil, you know, that anything that he's done or, you know, how he's communicating or anything like that, it's, I just said, don't put so much technical because he was, you know, in his notes, he was putting
all this, you know, all the things that I was reading to like, okay, here's, you know, kind of checking off the troubleshooting, the, you know, it made sense to me, but in his world, he was like, you know, because we were talking about fingerprints and we were talking about, you know, like just the whole authentication model and, and it just,
Not that he didn't understand it. He just, he thought we made the change, you know, and so he was fired up because we made the change. And I'm like, we did not make any changes. We're not in the business of making a change just for fun, you know, without letting you know, you know. So he, he, we had to talk him off the ledge, but
I just want to put back that Able is doing fantastic work. And if we ever come across another Able, please let me know. You know, of we're definitely in that market. So.
No, no, yeah, good insight, Tim, because I closely work with Abel. He's always busy doing a lot of stuff, working on...
OK.
I want lots of Abels too. Let's get more.
Yeah, right. And a good thing, he never said no, no matter. I think it was the last week incident when you get some ticket, I think. So I think no one was ready to work on the ticket or maybe probably don't know how to fix it, but he was not even sure how to fix it, but he picked the ticket and said, oh, we'll fix it.
Exactly, exactly.
Right.
So that's like the confident and he trusts, you know, that yeah, that I can fix it. So the support is available. So that's good to hear. I think few points that I'm not sure, like I know you're outside, not in the office. So the few point that probably we need to discuss. So is it good time or do you think is?
Yes.
And.
Yeah, no, go ahead, go ahead.
So I think, yeah, I'll start with Abel first. I think, Natalie, just for your reference, we had this conversation in the, I think, last to last month when we have the Abel 60-90 day, that plan that you shared, Tim, right? But I checked with Abel, a lot of things move around here and there. So I'm not sure how that plan has been executed.
Okay.
Yup.
how far and I have the entire whatever he is doing, how much he has achieved, what all tasks are pending. So that's one of touch base on that. Are we following the same? Because somehow we need to evaluate, make sure, yeah.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah, it's actually, yeah, that's actually a really good point. I haven't, you know, with the disruption we had inside of our team and in our leadership, I haven't, let me take that out and work, just kind of re-look at that and realign for the next, you know, 30 days, because I think we're at that spot where it's
Yeah.
everything that I could have ever asked for is where he's at, right? But I also want to make sure that all of us are on the same page and that, and especially for him, he's getting what he wants, you know, and I'm not putting him in a spot where he's like, wait, that's not what I agreed to, you know, so I don't want that to happen either. So I just know the conversation, he comes with
you know, the best attitude, the best smile, the best, all those things of anything you need, Tim, any, you know, and I just, I love that. So I just don't want to take advantage of that or put him in a spot where he's not liking it. So.
No, no, yeah, right. So now all the purpose is to make sure whatever the task he has aligned, right? So we'll make sure that he's aligned. We're monitoring him because I know he's doing a lot of things. So all those things are trackable after down maybe three months, six months, if we don't have track all those things that he's doing, right? Because I know a lot of things that he do offline.
Right, right.
working on different dashboard, et cetera. So he really don't, you know, record that all times and everything, you know. So I know, you know, right? Natalie know how good is able, but I think tomorrow if we need to present able to data price, end of the day numbers matter, right? So we need some fine, maybe a mechanism where we can show that this is what all he has.
Right.
Yes.
No, yeah.
Prince.
Doing and the progress that he made, you know.
That's a really good point because that's the discussion I'm having with my team members who aren't putting in their time, you know, because they're, we're in the inverse productivity curve right now for our overall team morale team. You know, everybody's like, screw this place, you know, so the more we can put in, the more we can get the bull's eye to move off of us, you know, and so the more I can show.
No.
from a management standpoint that yes, we are delivering and we are building and you know, for all, everybody on our team, but mainly for those guys too, to show the value. No, I totally agree.
Right, yeah. So, and the thing there, of course, Vikas and Alberto, so I mean, you also communicated, I also communicated them to make sure they give their best, whatever the ticket they're getting on alert board, anything, try to achieve at least 70% or above than 70% of the utilization, you know. So no matter what tickets they're getting, try to pull the ticket.
Get help from Abel, you know, so where they can deliver more, so yeah, but just I wanna check based on for both how they are doing both Vikas and Alberto.
Yep.
And that's super helpful, yeah.
Yeah, no, I think both, yeah, you know, again, those three, you know, do probably 40% of our tickets, you know, or more, you know, and so it's definitely, we wouldn't be able to do what we're doing without them. So I think what I can do is I can help show and at least, and I think, again, build that case for more,
IT by design resources and because the math just works, you know, and I think that's the part that we can we can work together to come up with that strategy and really present this. Probably not right now. I need to like wait and kind of wait until the dust settles a little bit more, but I can't. What we have right now is not sustainable. And that was my.
Yep.
pitch this morning is I can't keep doing what we're doing. And Natalie, you opened up this week to an idea for, you know, project work or, you know, just short term work too that could help assist where we're at or what we're trying to achieve. Because, you know, right now I have so many direct
from Data Prize of we must move all of our customers off of Sentinel One to CrowdStrike. We must, you know, and all these things where you're like, we're also trying to keep the lights on, trying to make customers happy, you know, like we can't keep doing more with less. And that's the part that, you know, maybe what I need to do is start putting, you know, hey, if we want to get this, because everybody wants it done by the end of June.
June and you're like, there's no way, like I can't get all this done and keep all the tickets moving, you know? So I think those are things that if there are ways that we can, you know, present or at least put ideas together, you know, and kind of build a, I don't know what a statement of work would look like, but at least for, hey, I need help with X or, you know, just even short-term stuff, you know, that might be.
might be an idea too.
Yeah, I mean, Aman is a pro, so lean on him if you need help with the directives that you have and how we can scope out the projects and we'll figure out who we have that can support there.
Perfect, perfect.
Yeah, no, that's.
Yeah, good. So I think the one thing which probably I was looking, we had discussed, I know you were busy, so I did not bother you. So kind of the visibility of what they are doing, right? But as of now, what the practice I follow, I individually walk to the engineer, Vikram, Alberto, and Abel, check their connect wise, what all they are doing, right?
what tickets they're working, how many hours they're delivering, what ticket they have on the board, kind of review their tickets. So that's kind of a lot of manually efforts where I have to connect because I know sometimes they're busy on a call. So I was looking kind of centralized way where I get the access for the maybe the connect wise. I think we'll discuss this.
Yep.
So where I have the visibility to see what all they're doing, make kind of process better. That is the one way, maybe set up a, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, I would, I would love to, yeah, I would love to get that. And I think, because right now, do you have access on the BrightGauge side?
No, no, that's yeah, I was waiting for the bright gaze and of course the connect wise or maybe another base.
Interesting, OK.
Yeah, let's make sure I get that to you. I'll get that. That's a huge priority for me to get that to you, because that's, I thought we had done that, but maybe that was for someone else. I'll go look through that.
Probably the...
No.
Was it with Oculus? Maybe what did we need to switch it? Yeah, so you may just need to switch the license too, yeah.
Nah.
Oh, I can listen.
I think that's, yeah.
Backlister.
Yep, yep, yep. And it's just a viewer. I mean, it's just super easy. Yep.
Yeah, maybe.
Dubey.
And another thing maybe for the connect device probably if the access maybe I think one thing that we are following the good like a AP access for the connect device. So where I have the centralized view for for the ticket board that what they're working or view their tickets, you know, see what all priority tickets that you have so that way they can deliver. I can keep eyes on.
all the board tickets that you have, right, and make sure they are aligned. If they're missing anything, I can coach them. Yeah.
Oh, I...
I'm gonna, yeah.
No, I love it. So what I'm going to do is I'm going to put a request in. I'm not sure how the ConnectWise license works. So let me let me see if I can get one for, you know, just from adding you as another engineer, maybe is what I'll request. And that'll give you access to our boards and just see if if that's something that we have a license on that one. But the bright gauge one I can do
Right now, like, I'll get when I get back to my office, I'll get that set up for you, so...
Yeah, for the ConnectWise, if license would be maybe the problem, just like API keys, only the board that Alberto, Vikas, and Abel work, and only read access for that, so only I can fetch the ticket information, what all they're working, limited only that not.
Right, right.
Do you even need a license then? You don't even need a license for API. That's good.
Oh no, we're gonna put, no, we're gonna put you, we're gonna put you to...
No, then an hour, yeah.
Wait, you don't need a license for what?
A Priya.
Yeah.
Oh.
the numbers and everything, their time sheet, their tickets, how many ticket they're closing, how many hours they're delivering, right? So that doesn't require even a license for anything.
Oh, interesting. Okay.
Oh, wait, can you email, can you email me? Yeah, can you email me that of what you need? Just so that, because I don't tell anybody, but before Michael left, he made me an admin. So I wonder if that's something I can just, I can just, don't tell anyone, don't tell anyone.
And I can probably shoot you an email, yeah.
Cool.
I'm not, I won't tell anyone. This is Aman.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Well, that's like that way. I think it's very good the way we have trying to get through the APS access, which give us more visibility for all the board that you have about the engineer and everything. So few things we should probably like, yeah.
Ohh, 100%.
But is it, do you just need, you just need it for that board though? Don't you need it for all the, like all the boards or is it just that one, like our support desk board?
Uhh...
Now, what all the board that all these three engineer work, Abel, Albert, and Vikas? Yeah.
Okay, okay, gotcha. I see what you're saying. Okay, gotcha. Okay.
And then access only for stick to the read access only. And I'll send you an email what information required. So it's not like it's going to fetch anything for your any other information, just the ticket related information only. So where I can track their SLA, I can track the ticket resolution rate, I can track the SLA rate for all the tickets, you know.
Perfect. That would be great.
Yep, yep.
That's awesome.
Okay.
Yeah, no, that's fantastic.
Yeah, so that way more visibility. So if anything I've found that we can make better or they can take care, right, I'll encourage them to make sure they are delivering, you know.
Daum.
No, I love it. Yeah, I know, it's super helpful having you guys, just having you, you know, being there just to make sure that if they have questions or, you know, to ask for help too, so.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think that's the piece that I have. I mean, I know we had discussion in the last call, but I know that you're busy, so I even ask Evil if, see if you can get a hold of Tim and ask this information later, let's go to next service call.
Okay.
Yeah, and just, hey, just know though, even though I'm busy, I love being like, I don't call it heckling, but I like being like, hey, can I help? Or can I, you know, just know that you don't worry about bugging me. Like I'm not that type of person where it's like,
Yeah.
you know, if you have a question, because I think you can teams me too, so go ahead and teams it over, you know, yeah, yep. So, yep, so definitely do never ever feel like you're bothering me or you know what I mean? Like to all you have a green light to contact me at any time. So.
Yeah, we have opened the infederation, yeah.
Manu.
Thank you for that. But I think because what I little discrepancy I saw and I'm not sure maybe something not right on the BrightGaze side because when I see the BrightGaze utilization for all those engineers, those number looks pretty different when I validate it manually in the ConnectWise, those number.
Yeah.
Okay.
Look pretty different.
So, yeah, takes one thing.
Yeah, that's good. Yeah, the more you can help me on that too, because that is definitely one of my, there is a calculation and it doesn't take into calculation two time off. And that's where numbers, it's a hard number to come up with, you know, so.
Yeah.
Exactly right, because I just get that bright gay screenshot from Abel. So if I look for the utilization from for Vikas, it shows 98%. Alberto, it shows almost 70, 80%. When I calculate as per the ConnectWise data, it is.
But.
Okay.
And...
Sixty, fifty-five, I mean, half of four, half of the, yeah.
Yeah, and when I...
What I did there, just because I wanted to calculate time off as well, so I adjusted it instead of being that, you know, 2000 hours, I did it with a lower number. So let me, I'll, yeah, let's get access. Let's work together on that and figure out, you know, if there's how you're doing it.
No.
And again, I think that will be super helpful to drive and especially the right accurate number. I don't want to fake anything either, but definitely wanted to make sure. Yeah, so.
Yeah, exactly.
That's why I did not, I mean I prepared the deck for all the data, but when I ask Abel to just give me the like a screenshot of the bright gaze, so those number look pretty different and what I have collected manually from the connector, but it is altogether different, so here's difference.
Yup.
Right, right. You're like, what is Tim doing? And I'm like, well, I'm trying to make our picture look good to the uppers, you know, that are looking at it. So definitely not trying to fake anything, but definitely want to make it. That was my first attempt at adding in time off, since I don't have time off.
Ashish.
Yeah.
Exactly.
It's all in the math.
Entered, you know, and exactly, exactly, so...
Goo.
Uh, because I with screenshot I I get from Abel, it it shows like uh, because deliver ninety-eight percent. I I said, oh, it's not possible that you deliver ninety-eight percent.
Oh, he's 98%. No, he's no, it's no, it totally makes sense. Let me, I'll get you the access. Let's work together. But I do want to make sure that, you know, whatever numbers we do come up with does tell the full story, you know, for what we're doing. So.
See.
Yeah.
Exactly right. Yeah, that's I think most the challenge I have seen in the able work because you do a lot of things, but I was checking with him a while ago, what all offline work that you're doing, where you are recording this time, because he said like ticket time he records all this, but whatever like dashboard that he creating, that AI stuff that he's doing, you don't have any.
Right.
Yep.
tickets or anything where you can put the time then maybe after yeah.
I thought, I thought we had, sorry, I thought we had created a ticket for him to do all of that, because I definitely want to keep track of that and make sure he's getting points for that, you know, so, and that can be just an internal PEI ticket, you know, so it doesn't have to even be a, but definitely want to make sure he's getting credit for that.
Yeah, exactly.
So...
No, no, so I can do one thing and I'll email you what information required.
Have you?
Have you guys leveraged his skill set and scaled that out to other customers?
As of now, we want him to be only for a data prize. We get the work fantastic job that is doing. If we propose someone else, someone else is going to ask Abel. So we have only one Abel.
Ohh, okay, perfect, perfect.
Yeah.
Das.
Well, I just, no, I mean, okay, okay, gotcha, gotcha. No, I hear ya.
No, but we have, so he joins, we have the, I mean, he's pretty much an Aman, right? Like you, your team in that Noida office is like leading our AI initiative. So Abel's actually been coming on the AI calls and like presenting. So like he's helping us in that way and like we're seeing, like, so he's showing us the things that he's doing.
Yeah.
Yep, no, that's good.
Exact.
Ohh, that's awesome.
That's awesome.
Yeah, so he's been like an MVP for that.
Good. Okay. Okay. Well, I just I just want to make sure you keep keep that guy like, you know, really focused in on his development because man, he just he keeps building and building and it's like, man, that is so cool. It kind of reminds me of how I used to be. Now I'm just lazy and just.
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Probably he gonna tell you he he he.
Back in my day, that's all I was. Tinkering around.
Exactly, exactly.
He has built, I think this morning was looking, he has built something very unique. Probably Tim ask him or he'll definitely show you. So he have created a jag run where he use or control his computer from his finger and eye. So he turn on the camera, right? So he move his hand left, right, his eye. See move like.
Oh my god. Oh, that's funny. That is funny.
Kind of movie thing, yeah.
Awesome, I saw the demo.
So he was doing some fun activities sideways and yeah. So I think we're aligned. Yeah, so I'll touch base you on what information I needed. But I think maybe next week, if you maybe have like a 20, maybe 10, 15 minute, 20 minutes, I can just kind of show you what is the plan, how the data will look like, right? So that way you have the clear visibility that how the ConnectWise data is going to look like at.
That is hilarious.
Okay.
OK, yeah, I'll be.
Yeah, yeah, just you bet.
our site right what metrics, KPIs number will show and how it's going to help you and our team to be grow further you know.
Perfect. No, that makes good sense, so...
Yeah, right. So thank you, Tim, for all your time.
Alright, well, thank you, yeah.
Have a great weekend, then we'll talk next week.
Yep, you bet. Have a great weekend. Yes, sounds good. Alright, bye-bye.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you, Natalie. Take care. Bye.
Yeah.